Aloha everyone from beautiful Hawaii
we are here on the island of Oahu where
I did a lot of my growing up as you know
Hawaii means so much to my family and me
and the traditions of our Ohana or
aiinga as we say in Samoa were shaped by
these incredible Islands the Pacific
Islands and their cultures inspired a
very special Story one that you all know
very well and that story is drum roll
please
Moana that's right we are so excited and
happy to announce that a live action
reimagining of Moana is in the works
Moana Grandma tala the music the dance
te fiti puer the pig the village the
beautiful powerful ocean and one more
what's that guys oh Yours Truly hey hey
the chicken kidding hey hey is going to
be in it but of course Maui will be in
it too
[Music]
many of you may not know the brilliant
team at Disney Animation my partners we
found so much inspiration from Maui in
the Mana and the presence of my late
grandfather the legendary High Chief
Peter Maivia he would walk in light up
the room the energy the tattoos the hair
the bod when you're staring at a demigod
thank you sorry I get caught up in the
moment
so as you guys can see perfect timing as
the sun comes out just how deep the
story is for me because in a way when I
bring Maui to life I'm doing it in the
spirit of my grandfather so uh it's
still very early in the process there's
so much more work to be done but until
then there is one more thing that I need
to kick this journey off right hey girls
do you want to get uh that special thing
that Daddy needs wow you guys are
Daddy's daughters you are so strong
thank you guys so much we're gonna go in
the ocean yes oh look at the love I have
is Daddy Maui
you guys want ice cream
see so Daddy's Maui
foreign